[Music]
[Applause]
we got some prop bets coming up this
weekend and ross tucker the brand
ambassador for draftking sportsbook
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56 giving you new customers 56 to 1
odds on either team just bet 5 get 280
and free bets if your team wins download
the draftking sportsbook app use the
promo code patrick get 56-1 odds on
either team bet just 5 get 280 in free
bets if your team wins that's
codepatrick at draftkings sportsbook
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast cbs westwood one color
analyst ross good morning how are you
buddy
dan i am fantastic i would definitely be
better if i was getting a chance to see
you guys in person and
sitting on the sactional but i'm very
appreciative and glad i could join you
anyway what's the uh food spread uh this
weekend for you
you know that's an interesting question
uh i'm actually incredibly lame
on super bowl sunday so this is i
typically don't work the super bowl this
is the first weekend believe it or not
since the eagles first preseason game
august 11th well i guess last weekend
was that i'm not traveling to broadcast
at least one game
and the first couple times i did it dan
i would go to like a super bowl party
around here
but you probably know how it's how it is
like i'm at a super bowl party and the
doctor to my right is asking me a
question this guy's got the business
what do you think about this i just
don't have a lot of interest in people
talking to me
while i'm watching the super bowl so a
lot of times i'm pretty lame
when it comes to what i eat on the super
bowl i think what i might try to do this
year
if i can pull it off
i might go to the super bowl party like
an hour early i might cross crush some
buffalo chicken dip
have a few wings of course the drums not
the flats drums are way better than
flats that's common knowledge uh maybe
some hummus so i feel good about myself
i'll stick some carrots or some celery
and some hummus if everything a hummus
you have
offsets a wing so like i'll alternate to
feel better about myself but then 15
minutes before the game starts i'll
leave and come back home so i can watch
in solitude and i'll have people ask me
questions yeah my wife said
uh do you want to have a party and i go
good god no
a guy i just want to sit
i don't want to talk to anybody i just
want to watch that's it and she goes
okay
give me just a little tequila cigar
that's it just watch the football in
solitude don't have to answer any of
those questions now do you have a
favorite prop bet
i do i've got a couple actually okay one
is
and you're going to laugh at me about
this
i love the tales on the coin toss oh
it's a misnomer that a coin is 50 50 dan
okay have you ever looked at a coin
the head kind of juts out a little bit
as a guy paulie's talked about this as a
guy with a huge head okay i can speak to
this
the head side is heavier look at a coin
okay the tail side is flat the head side
of whoever it is the george washington
abraham lincoln i don't even know who it
is whoever it is the head side juts out
a little bit and it's a big head so the
head is actually heavier as a guy with
one of the biggest heads on television
filling up the whole peacock screen
right now i can tell you the head side
is heavier tails wins 58 of the time i
think maybe i'm not sure i like tails
and then in terms of the actual football
i like both quarterbacks to go over
their rushing yardage props for borough
it's 11 and a half at draftkings for
matthew stafford it's five and a half at
draftkings here's the thing though dan
those yardage totals they're based on
the whole season like these numbers are
based on the 20 game body of work
this is the super bowl we've seen john
elway do the helicopter at like 36 years
old we saw joe burrow last week scramble
for four third down conversions stafford
can run a little bit five and a half
yards for stafford that's one run burrow
is going to be under pressure the whole
game he's going to take off at least
once he might get the 11.5 yards in one
run maybe it's two
over quarterback rushing has been
awesome this postseason i'm gonna
continue to ride it with both borough
and stafford over at draftkings okay but
i was wondering about this ross do they
factor in the yards lost on sax
and does that affect your running
numbers as a quarterback
no
great question no they don't they do in
college football they do not in the nfl
so sac yardage lost does not go against
the quarterback's rushing yards however
dan it's a great question
taking a knee does
if you remember the chiefs niners super
bowl a couple years ago
the chiefs have the lead mahomes was
over
his rushing yardage prop
for some unknown reason dan rather than
just taking a knee and like losing a
yard
mahomes was trying to take a couple
extra seconds off the clock so twice he
backed up like five yards and then took
a knee if you guys google it or you see
what people were tweeting at the end of
that super bowl people were losing their
minds people lost their mahomes over
rushing yardage prop on the two knees he
took at the end of that game
we do have some research on the heads
and tails paulie yeah ross is right a
stanford professor said it's 51.5
for tails because of the weight issue
and that the heads would have more
chance to
affect the bounce off a flat service and
they did it like weeks and weeks of
testing what other prop bits do you do
you like here
can i just say something real quick yeah
i was totally joking
i didn't know that
i am a i am back now it's not like it's
a princeton researcher stanford like
second-tier school but still i am amazed
that is awesome um i i like uh i like
tyler boyd under receiving yardage love
tyler i called all of his high school
games but jalen ramsey plays in the slot
dan i mean they don't move jaylen ramsey
around that much people oh jamar chase
jalen ramsey i doubt it that's not what
the rams have done this year jalen
primarily plays in the slot that's not
good for tyler boyd so i would take the
under
on boyd's receiving yardage probably
over on cooper cup now it's over a
hundred i think it's 102 and a half
maybe up to 104
at draftkings for cooper cup but dan the
guy has gone over
14 of 20 games this year the guy is a
machine i'm i mean he'll win offensive
player of the year tonight i'm sure
i'm still not sure people realize
the season that cooper cup has had this
is randy moss 2007 this is any
he's not only won the triple crown for
touchdowns receptions yards nobody was
particularly close he won the yards by
like 400 the catches by double digits
the touchdowns over mike evans by three
i mean he smoked everybody across the
board
i don't think he's gonna get shut down
in the super bowl i'm going over cooper
cup although
mike hilton the bengals nickelback is
pretty good that's a good matchup
he's ross tucker brand ambassador for
the great folks at draftkings i wanted
to ask you about being a former
offensive lineman and if you were on the
bengals offensive line right now
going against the rams what is your
strategy since it feels like the game is
going to hinge on
how good that offensive line is or isn't
on sunday
yeah so i think a lot of it's a great
question i think a lot of that depends
on how the bengals
elect to help those guys you know those
guys are competitive
those guys are confident
but they know what they're going against
they know von miller is an excellent
player leonard floyd's excellent player
and they know aaron donald is
unbelievable so that's not like nobody's
there's no secrets here the bengals
offensive line isn't good the bengals
know that the rams know that you know
that i know that the the rams d aaron
dylan's an amazing player so what it
really is incumbent upon even more than
the players in my mind is what the
coaches come up with
to protect the offensive line is it
burro getting the ball out of his hands
quickly is it do they try to run the
ball more with joe mixon they ran it
very well in overtime against the chiefs
last time we saw them do they do more
two tight end sets so that the tight
ends run through the outside armpit of
both the ends both edge rushers floyd
and von miller that way the interior
trio can really focus on aaron donald
obviously you need to get help i
remember there were times dan you
remember the guy remember tommy harris
for the bears he had like a three or
four year run where he was unbelievable
i can remember playing for cleveland
and it was cozy coleman and joe andruzzi
and i might have been supposed to slide
left
but we kind of decided amongst us
whoever has tommy harris one-on-one
that's where i was going to help like i
was you know going to look that way
first but i mean there's certain guys
that you you have to help them and the
guard needs to know he's having that
help aaron donald is that guy
how do the rams lose this super bowl
uh probably
in my mind two ways
one is matthew stafford
turnovers leads the nfl and pick sixes
the bengals have been pretty good at
causing turnovers they've got some ball
hawks with jesse bates
you know mike hilton did a nice job i
think a rams loss
looks like
two interceptions for stafford maybe one
goes back to the house i also think
perhaps if the rams play
a single high safety which i wouldn't
recommend
i think t higgins and jamar chase have
favorable matchups on the outside
against the corner because jalen ramsey
primarily inside at the nickel i think
joe burrow like he's done all year
he will just throw it up to those guys
i don't think i've ever seen dan
a guy have more faith
in terms of contested catches with a
receiver
with the stature of jamar chase
burrow even in the red zone even on the
goal line
burrow throws the ball to jamar chase
dan
like he's randy moss like he's some
like he's calvin johnson jamar chase is
not that big of a kid but burro doesn't
care he just trusts him to somehow make
the play a lot of times he does
great to talk to you buddy have a good
weekend and uh we'll talk to you next
week
always have a blast i've been enjoying
listening to you guys i hope ryan in uh
honolulu destroys fritzy tomorrow
that'll be hilarious
wow
the the mock-off crater look i got i
gotta i gotta support chat row i gotta
support you fritz you know i love you
but i gotta support chat row and ryan
and honolulu all right
all right
i don't think draftkings has prop bets
on uh mock headlines wow the markov
thank you thank you ross the uh brand
ambassador for uh
uh draftkings